Hey, it's Henry.
So this is the last episode of our season.
And it turns out, we have some
extra money in the budget,
and I want to spend that money on myself.
So for this episode, we're going
to figure out how a person,
in this case, me, can spend money
to increase their own happiness.
Now I know what you're thinking,
"Money can't buy happiness."
And you're right.
Sort of.
Studies have found that while
having more money greatly
affects the happiness for
people living in poverty,
once someone earns around $75,000 a year,
the amount of happiness they get
from additional funds flattens out.
So someone who makes on
average $200,000 a year
isn't necessarily that
much happier than somebody
who makes a middle class salary, like me.
So it's kind of unbelievable
to hear that, you know,
me doubling my salary
wouldn't make me any happier.
But while more money
doesn't necessarily mean
more happiness, how we
spend our money does.
And like any good reporter,
I did a Google search,
and watched a TED Talk on happiness
by this man, Dr. Robert Waldinger.
He's the director of the Harvard
Study of Adult Development,
a study that started in 1938,
and continues until this day,
making it possibly the longest
study of human happiness
ever to have been conducted.
We found that many of the things we expect
to predict well-being do,
like taking care of yourself,
taking care of your health, not smoking,
not abusing alcohol, okay, exercising.
But the surprise was that the
quality of our relationships
with other people actually
keeps us healthier
and keeps us alive longer.
So we looked at their
cholesterol, we looked
at their blood pressure at age 50.
And we looked at their
marital satisfaction.
And what we found was that
their marital satisfaction was
by far the strongest predictor
of what they were gonna
be like when they were 80.
Happiest marriages at 50,
predicted better health
and happiness at age 80.
But to be able to predict across 30 years,
that's a big deal, that
begins to get at causation.
So relationships, it's
like exercise in a way,
you don't just do it one week,
and then you're done, right?
That relationships have to be tended to.
So your marriage, your
friendships, they take work,
they take constant attention
over time, or they wither away.
So how can I buy good relationships?
Well, you can't, but,
but, that is a question you
should ask of the researchers
who actually study this.
Luckily, these researchers
also had TED Talks.
And have been focusing
on that very question,
how spending our money
affects our happiness.
The reason why I believe it's
actually very interesting
to study spending is
because it's so ubiquitous,
we all spend and we all
actually have a lot of control
over our spending.
We are going to spend some of our money
because we have to, and
are we really thinking
about spending it in ways that
might actually make us happy?
And if yes, what can we learn
as researchers to help people?
So there's a lot of methodology
and findings that come
from research done by people
like Sandra and Michael,
but I wanted to boil down
some of the biggest takeaways.
First off, and this
shouldn't come as a surprise,
but spend money on building
social relationships,
Though there is built into
our close relationships
this element of reciprocity,
of giving back and forth,
What we're trying to do in our research
is say you can do more of it, actually.
So it's probably not useful
to give someone $5 and say,
"Will you be a closer friend of mine?"
because that's not how it works.
But it does work to say,
"Hey, I really like you.
"And I'd like to take you out to lunch."
So if you buy coffee, maybe
you might want to spend it
on buying coffee for
yourself and your friend.
Because we know that if you
spend it on someone else,
you also gain greater happiness.
The next big point is to spend more money
on experiences and less on things.
Tom Gilovich and his
colleagues at Cornell,
for about a decade now,
have been doing research
showing that, on average, buying stuff
for yourself doesn't do
much for your happiness.
But buying experiences
seems to make us happier.
What we see when we when
it comes to actually buying
material goods versus
experiences is that when we buy
our second watch, for example,
we might get the spike
in happiness, but at some point
this actually, this effect
of happiness goes away.
And to some extent, we might
even regret at some point
spending, investing that much money.
Whereas if we have experiences,
we can go to a concert,
there's this effect of
anticipated happiness,
and we look forward to going
to the concert for two weeks,
even like building up to the experience.
And then after the experience,
we can always go back to it.
So we have a memory of the experience.
We might even share it with friends,
come back to it every once in a while,
you know, when we get
together for a fun night.
And finally, if you've been thinking,
"I do want that Apple
Watch, and I know it would
"make me happy," then good, buy it,
you should know what makes you happy.
If people manage to spend
their money in a way
that is aligned with their
own psychological needs
and preferences as reflected
by their personality,
then that seems to be
making people happier.
If I'm an extrovert, I might be better off
spending my money on going
out with friends, kind of,
having a very social time,
spending it on exciting stuff.
Versus like a friend
of mine who's probably
more introverted, what
they could do instead
is spend it on things
that improve their quality
me time, so to say.
The first thing that we
recommend that people do
is literally do an audit of your spending.
And what's important to you
is completely up to you,
so I can't say these are the things
that should be important to you in life,
but you know the things that
are important to you in life.
And typically, when you
look at your spending
in this way, you say, "Wow, I
should really shift some money
"from that big category
over to this big category."
So to recap the big takeaways,
in order to spend money
to get happiness, first
off, know yourself.
Are you an introvert, an extrovert?
How do you want to spend your money?
Second, use your money to
build social relationships.
And third, put an emphasis
on experiences over things.
So if I were to analyze
myself for my money,
if I'm getting the best return,
I am a person who loves my family
and I love sharing experiences
with them around food.
So I'm thinking I will spend
that extra budget money,
you know, for the purposes of the show,
to take my mom with me to Italy
and we have some fantastic meals.
What are we looking at?
Yeah, it's--
So, it turns out we got like $35.20 left
in the budget, so...
Hey, Mom, do you want to go
to the Olive Garden tonight?